what we're going to do in this video is
prove to ourselves that the derivative
with respect to X of natural log of X is
indeed equal to 1 over X so let's get
started
so just using the definition of a
derivative if I were to say the
derivative with respect to X of natural
log of X that is going to be the limit
as Delta X approaches 0 of the natural
log of X plus Delta X minus the natural
log of X all of that over Delta X so now
we can use a few logarithm properties we
know that if I have the natural log of a
minus the natural log of B this is equal
to the natural log of a over B so we can
use that right over here where have the
natural log of something minus the
natural log of something else so all of
this is going to be equal to the limit
as Delta X approaches 0 of the natural
log of this divided by that so X plus
Delta X over X X plus Delta X over X all
of that over Delta X and actually let me
just write it that way all of that over
Delta X once again all I did if I have
natural log of that minus natural log of
that that's the same thing as natural
log of this first expression divided by
that second expression come straight out
of our logarithm properties well inside
of this logarithm X divided by X is 1
and then Delta X divided by X we could
just write that as Delta x over X so
that's another way of writing that and
then we could put a 1 over Delta X out
front so we could say this is the same
thing as this is equal to the limit as
Delta X approaches 0 of I'll do this in
another color so this I can rewrite as 1
over Delta x times the natural log of
one plus one plus Delta X over X let me
close that parentheses so now we can use
another exponent property if I have I'll
write it out here if I have a times the
natural log of B that is equivalent to
the natural log of B to the a and so
here this would be the a in that case so
I could bring that out and make that an
exponent on this so this is all going to
be equal to the limit as Delta X
approaches 0 of the natural log of give
myself some space 1 1 plus Delta X over
X to the 1 over Delta X power 1 over
Delta X power now this might start to
look familiar to you it might start to
look close to the definition of e and we
are indeed getting close to that in
order to get there fully I'm going to do
a change of variable I am going to say
let's let let's let n equal Delta X over
X Delta X over X well in that case then
if you multiply both sides by X you get
Delta X is equal to n X again just
multiply both sides of this equation by
X and swapped the sides there and then
if you wanted 1 over Delta X 1 over
Delta X that would be equal to 1 over N
X which we could also write as 1 over N
times 1 over X actually let me write it
this way actually that's the way I do
want to write it so these are all the
substitutions that I want to do my
change of variable and we also want to
say well look as Delta X is approaching
0 what is n going to approach well as
Delta X approaches 0 we have n will
approach 0 as well 0 over X well that's
just going to be 0 for
any X that is not equal to zero and
that's okay because zero is not even in
the domain of natural log of X so this
is going to be for our domain it works
that is Delta X approaches zero and
approaches zero and you can think about
the other way around as n approaches
zero Delta X approaches zero so now
let's do our change of variable so if we
make the substitutions instead of taking
the limit as Delta X approaches zero we
are now going to take the limit as n
approaches zero of the natural log of
myself some parentheses and I'll say one
plus and now this is the same thing as n
1 plus n and then all of that is going
to be raised to the 1 over N times 1
over X that's what 1 over Delta X is
equal to this is 1 over Delta X right
over here which we have over here and
it's the same thing as 1 over N times 1
over X so let me write that down
so this is the same thing as 1 over N
times 1 over X now we can use this same
exponent property to go the other way
around well actually let me just rewrite
this another time so this is going to be
the same thing as the limit as n
approaches 0 of the natural log of 1
plus I'll just write this in orange 1
plus n to the 1 over n if I raise
something to exponent and that's times
something else I can that's the same
thing as raising it to the first
exponent and then raising that to the
second value this comes once again
straight out of our exponent properties
and now we can use this property the
other way to bring this one over X out
front but in fact the 1 over X itself is
not affected as n approaches 0 so we can
even take it completely out of the limit
so we could take it all the way over
there and this is when you should be
getting excited this will be equal to 1
over x times the limit
and approaches zero of the natural log
of 1 1 plus n we do that orange color 1
plus n to the 1 over N and now then what
really gets affected is what's going on
inside of the natural log that's where
all of the ends are and so let's bring
the limit inside of that so this is all
going to be equal to get myself some
space a little bit of extra chalkboard
space this is going to be equal to 1
over x times the natural log times the
natural log of the limit as n approaches
0 of 1 plus n to the 1 over N close
those parentheses now this is exciting
what is inside the natural log here well
this business right over here this is a
definition of the number e so that is
equal to e well what's the natural log
of e well that's just 1 so it's 1 over x
times 1 well that is indeed equal to 1
over X which is exactly the result that
we were looking for that the derivative
with respect to X of natural log of X is
1 over X very exciting